hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Brianna
white white Israel brought to a great
start when I gotta check out the video
dear skinny people and we got the wind
blowing I'm Briana and myself but it
does a much more dramatic effect for
Briana
many people enjoy let's see here dear
skinny people by David so comedy this is
a parody of dear fat people the video
that caused so much controversy cuz some
dumb idiot decided to make some dumb
jokes that just tanked and now people
think she's a [ __ ] I personally wasn't
that bothered by it but whatever is this
[ __ ] hairspray or Steven it's seeming
haha
you're [ __ ] people oh no there's
gonna be some angry people at this video
that's right skinny people what do you
do chase me cuz I go run what [ __ ] would
you think I'm gonna run [ __ ] I'm bad
I'm gonna do [ __ ] imma pop my ass on the
floor and you'll be like aren't you
gonna run I'll be like no [ __ ] suck a
dick what would you even think about
chasing me you should understand in it
when the cops come after me I'm like you
know what dude just get me check my
butthole a keister [ __ ] it's gonna be
like chasing a rock [ __ ] I ain't going
nowhere
no a lot of fun I'm running it up what
you doing [ __ ] I'm slower than a
[ __ ] zombie i watch like three
episodes of The Walking Dead and I
[ __ ] loved it
anybody that hates the vlogging it is
obviously a [ __ ] I'm gonna talk about
your appearance and you've been skinny
with no [ __ ] tact and by the way I
like doing random junk cuts for no
[ __ ] reason I'm here [ __ ] me now in
here [ __ ] upside-down Spartan [ __ ] me
screaming nothing skinny people make
that [ __ ] up
why the [ __ ] is it every time I'm with a
skinny person and it's cold they [ __ ]
shake ha mother [ __ ] bears have
insulation that's a survival tactic
maybe you should gets up every time
you're in a cold room you're wearing a
t-shirt and you're shivering and you're
wondering why random jump-cut maybe I do
it oh my and I'm not talking about
skinny people in third world countries
where they're starving to death because
they look fantastic insensitive comment
and if there are people out there with a
specific condition such as anorexia or
bulimia I'm just saying this so I can
take a little heat off my bag for being
a dumb [ __ ] I'm talking about the 65%
of North Americans that got their help
in check I'm talking about the 65% of
errors there are yes skinny you are so
[ __ ] skinny you are affecting your
own health whenever you eat a tic-tac it
looks like you have a beats by dre pill
in your stomach that's enough yes give
me that you are the only person on earth
that can sag a thong skinny boned it is
not a thing how stupid do I look really
[ __ ] stupid fishing okay oh that's
[ __ ] brilliant because that's not
real skinny people if I go out of my way
to insult you about you as a human being
and it helps you feel better about
yourself what then either you in my job
I'm glad that I can go out of my [ __ ]
way as you say it in the worst way
possible to affect you positively giddy
people
you look very uncomfortable how do you
[ __ ] walk in a buffet eat one thing
and say I got my money's worth that
doesn't [ __ ] make sense when I walk
into a buffet people question whether
they're going to make a profit that's
called getting your money's worth
scary people do you want to know why I
look so good being [ __ ] around em I'm
not a shame yes I am around here the
shake now suck a dick
ironic that a fat person's tell you ask
any person what to do it their life
rather Winker her skinny people you are
taking your body for granted how do you
feel when you wake up and you put on an
extra small shirt and it's still baggy
when I fart you cute over like this
that's right who came up with this
concept of skinny shaming hashtag skinny
shaming skinny people tell me this how
can you buy jeans and not fill them out
when you buy your pair of pants it's
also like buying disappointment nope I'm
not gonna fill these out my butt goes
inwards do you want to be fat and simple
all you have to do is eat mold you had
one serving you feel full guess what we
call that an appetizer you get the
second plate and then you feel like
you're going to burst
guess what take a [ __ ] do you know how I
know i fat every time I do a video I
sweat and so here's an interesting story
I went to the airport I sit down on my
[ __ ] seat and then there's this
skinny [ __ ] right next to me
number one did I sign up for some extra
arm room no [ __ ] I normal size so I
have to let you know that you're fat and
you're Monty she looks at me like I'm
invading her space [ __ ] aren't you
skinny aren't you always complaining
that you're cold coming to my [ __ ]
tip and that's mother yourself too you
can't bring this person was so mucking
skinny and irritated they have to push
and roll my fat over that should make
you happy
don't you always want to work out it's
just like pushing those tires but this
[ __ ] was coming over here complaining
that I smell like sausages [ __ ] when
you go with your daddies what do you
expect to smell you like that smell
[ __ ] especially sausages Hydra
sometimes I am so bad at that I am that
standing sweat [ __ ] we're crystal comes
out my skin which is why I still look
really young yeah I'm actually 52 by the
Magma's have my random racists coming in
here big sassy
women that our fattest fun or
entertaining because they're fat in
blanket I saw them in a Madea movie why
is it so hard on you to get fat it's
simple for me yesterday I breathe in
oxygen I gained 10 pounds you know how
you realize when you're fat when you
miss the amount of food but your Dookie
comes out this small why where did it go
see I don't like giving positive words
of encouragement it doesn't make sense
because it's a problem that you can fix
easily right because food is not an
addiction you have to realize something
skinny people if you want to be fat you
have to put the work in like for me I am
now addicted to food I like the way food
makes me feel and guess what getting
skinny oh my god it's so [ __ ] easy
all I have to do is not eat right it
doesn't give me any emotional pain I
didn't grow up having people tell me I'd
less of a human being because I'm
[ __ ] fat because all the skinny
people got the best answers on earth
yes skinny people is time that you be
fed so I could share you the love of
being fat because fat people have never
tried losing weight they never struggled
with being [ __ ] to hate it for the
way they look
so fat people the next time you see a
skinny person give them and McDouble
give them a [ __ ] sandwich and punch
them in their chest because they're
stupid for being skinny skinny people
you should want to be fat because
according to other people they want to
enjoy us as human beings only if we're
skinny because therefore fat convert
other people is this coming my hair
because yes it is ha ha ha papers doing
all you do so a lot of you guys have
suggested that I do this video I'm doing
this super [ __ ] last minute but if
you can tell this is a parody satire on
the girl who made this video so yeah a
lot of the jokes are insensitive much
like the girls and kind of there's a
play on that I could preface this with
this [ __ ] because a lot of people just
might not get it but you know some
people just gonna [ __ ] but yeah yeah
look at the messages of holes you saying
I guess care about yourself enough to
lose weight and be healthy but you get
in a way where you were demeaning people
and you're making fun of how they are
and who they are as a person rather than
the actual problems you kind of [ __ ]
done for that but you say you're a
comedian so I hopefully you do
and how to package up jokes a little
better that anyways hope you guys
enjoyed that video if you haven't I
don't know [ __ ] you do something about
it even if you don't like it they'll to
subscribe because I need you my lord
that guy he is so fun I've never seen
him before I've heard of him that's so
[ __ ] funny yeah that is exactly what
she should have done it's all along the
lines of that yes like poking if it's
satire you're supposed to be poking fun
at something that's kind of stupid in a
way like acting as if you're the idiot
you know yeah but she was acting like a
really young yeah exactly
so it didn't come across like it's funny
at all and I don't think that was her
intention either I think you just set
out to be mean this guy though
it's skinnier an is so funny funny
because skinny meet like people who
struggle like anorexia
yeah yeah a lot of people have real
struggles with that but I wasn't
watching this going this guy's an idiot
he's clearly making fun of people who
are dumb about it yes or arlynn well
that's exactly what that woman should
have done I just thought he had a really
good balance of actually mimicking the
video but also making his own point but
he also said some really interesting
things there about obesity and being
skinny too like we want to be fat like
we've never tried to lose weight really
I mean I thought I liked that I thought
he did a really really fabulous job of
kind of finding that balance between all
of the different aspects of it
I also liked how he did um the parody of
jump cuts oh my god the only thing I
wish you would have said is oh my god am
i jenna Marbles yet that's really
what a lot of people do comparator like
being a washed-up jenna Marbles
she's just trying so hard I felt like
she's trying way too hard eeeh this guy
though David so comedy I'm where's his
channel I got a subscribe to this
[ __ ] I appreciate him doing the
outro and I appreciate that he did put
it in the description box - that's a
parrot and the title says parody yes
there's gonna be plenty of people who
are not get it who don't get it in her
think he's just being a dick no I
thought what he did was fantastic and he
makes me feel more confident about my
fabulous you know you should be ashamed
of yourself reskinning you were totally
ashamed I hate how you're in shape I
like keep trying to eat but it's just
like I get full so fast yeah one chick
tack is all it takes
I wish I had oh my god that joke was
really funny right - tick tock joke yeah
that joke was really funny right you'll
laugh at that joke right it was a funny
one huh sorry it's the impression I got
from you sorry I'm sorry I wouldn't look
like no I'm sorry suddenly really
intimidated by you yeah well anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects you get what should I
promote for you right now your face
begins YouTube I have a video gaming
YouTube channel coming out soon
hopefully we're gonna have it running by
the end of the week um it's been a lot
of technical difficulties but we've
already got our channel our we've
already got her name so hopefully it's
gonna be up soon and she's also on
Facebook where you can find some awesome
modeling photos apparently I saw them
good job thank you good job you boys
will like it and you could follow us on
real rejects on those social networks
that were on shout out
Weasley so varied um can I give me a
wheeze Lisa very shout out he sent a
voice message can I please get a
shout-out ever on cuz hot she is pretty
hot I agree with that
that sounded like one of those like deep
dark web audio recordings it totally did
like that's some haunted [ __ ] oh if you
want you can also call me dick but my
name is Leslie I'll watch your YouTube
videos and they're [ __ ] funny even
though Bronchos they're the horror
movies and like your reaction on the
Star Wars video trailer
um the I know you didn't like the
Fantastic Four one but yeah me see
jogging or something watch the trailer
for Mission Possible
that [ __ ] movie was awesome so check
that out please um if you want you to
check out my page my name is Leslie
Siebert see her Seibert that's how you
pronounce his last name I feel like
that's a voicemail that I get from my
grandma
you know where she just kind like kind
of trails off and then remembers what
she wants to say and then kind of trails
off again but you just love her so much
for it I got the vibe that is not
grandma I got this is it this is the
subscriber who's such a loyal fan that
he's gonna murder me and he's not gonna
murder you he was just crying you could
clearly hear he was just driving yeah
where do you think he's driving to I
knew I shouldn't have posted my address
on Facebook I mean usually that's a
really good idea but maybe in your case
it was a bad idea it was a bad idea this
guy's like wedding out of breath and if
I don't respond to him he's gonna
[ __ ] murder me
yeah here at Creek I Wesley
remember you lock the doors